and for my for my own personal
um
sanity
because i've been getting my eyes kicked
ever since you left
so just for my own personal sanity how
much
did
our argument
against the clippers
drive you
to ultimately lead the warriors it
wasn't the argument it was the the way
that everybody steve kerr act like it
didn't happen bob myers and tried to
just discipline you and think that that
would put the mask over everything i
really felt like that was such a big
situation for us as a group the first
time we went through something like that
we had to get that [ __ ] all out i
remember watching the last dance
and when scotty didn't go into the game
the whole team in the locker room said
scotty that was [ __ ] up that you did
that we needed that we just needed to
throw all of that [ __ ] out on the table
and say yo jay
okay like that was [ __ ] up that we
even had to go through that let's just
wipe our hands with that and go go
finish the task i don't think we did
that we tried to dance around it i just
didn't like how all of that just the
vibe between all of that it just made
[ __ ] weird to me and i'd rather us
be who we say we are family first
communication is key like we didn't show
that and that's what rubbed me the wrong
way more than anything when we landed
back from l.a
i sat in a
hazel was sitting in the car for an hour
and 45 minutes they pulled me in that
room at signature for an hour and 45
minutes and they tried to tell me
you need to apologize
and i told them
i'll talk to kay but y'all aren't going
to tell me what i need to say
and you know they went on for hour and
45 minutes saying a bunch of [ __ ]
and ultimately they realized all right
we're not getting through to him we're
going to try again in the morning and so
we met the next morning and
they said all right
you slept on it you ready to apologize
and i told them right then and now i
said
y'all about to [ __ ] this up i said the
only person that can make this right
is me and kay
and there is nothing that y'all can do
and y'all are going to [ __ ] this up and
in my opinion they [ __ ] it up i think
so too
and they told me right then and they're
like we're going to suspend you for this
game
i laughed and if it literally laughed in
their face
and bob said to me he said um
wow
that was not the reaction i was looking
for or expecting and i said well either
i'm gonna laugh in your face or i'm
gonna cuss you the [ __ ] out so you pick
i'ma choose laugh so i think what you're
doing is funny
and so i'ma laugh and so it's
interesting to hear you say
essentially the same thing that i told
them
that day